driver and violently attacked one of the
officers police as well as three
citizens then
opened fire i would just like to take a
moment to remind
everyone the dangers of this job of
being a police officer
and we would also like to thank good
citizens that step in and help us in our
time of need
now the officer was transported to umc
she is being treated for her
injuries i'm told she's in stable
condition no word yet
on who the man is this is an ongoing
investigation so make sure you tune in
to 8 news now for the latest details
reporting live
sally jaramillo 8 news now
new at 5 o'clock the clark county school
district releasing an updated transition
plan to hybrid learning
now this is actually going to be a guide
for families to know more about the
school operations the procedures
as well as classroom instruction now the
district is also ironing out details on
transportation for all those
pre-kindergarten to third graders who
are returning
the document more than 200 pages long so
we're going to dig through it
break down what families and teachers
need to know right here for you at six
o'clock
also tonight frustrations and worry
continue as a lot of people who've
already received their first dose
are now just scrambling to try and get
that second appointment for their second
vaccine dose
today the health district said emails
are being sent out
joe moeller is live at the las vegas
convention center with more on what's
being said
and what's being done joe
imagine getting that first dose and then
trying to set up a second for a second
dose here at the convention center but
it is
all booked up now that is what many
people say is happening to them
is the one dose going to be even
valuable if i can't get the second nose
when they tell me i should
uh dragon and i apologize
patricia clark is worried she won't get
her appointment on february 17th in a
virtual news conference the health
district said they
are sending out more emails about second
appointments today or tomorrow
now this is happening due to technical
difficulties they said that
is where you will set up your next
appointment they also explain the grace
period for the second dose is up to six
weeks or 42 days
so if you don't get an appointment right
away when you're supposed to that should
be okay
so if you've had your vaccine from
a january 4 to like the 19th i will we
will be emailing you
for that
they also explained the website is still
being updated and they are working out
the issues now you are encouraged to
keep checking back
in claire county nearly 175 000 doses
were administered as of yesterday
each week clark county has been
receiving about 23
000 to 25 000 doses on today's vaccine
call they announced next week they will
be getting 27
000 doses so that is an increase now we
know many people simply want to talk to
someone on the phone about their
questions now take a look at the number
on your screen
702
this is the number people can call who
have to get the second dose
and have questions about that now we
know that people have been calling and
those phone lines have been busy so
today the health district did say that
they added staff
to help on those phone lines to answer
your questions so that is the number
you're going to want to call reporting
live here at the convention center joe
mullen eight news now
and folks you can find that number on
our website eight news down dot com the
i-team asking state leaders if there
will be consequences for people
who've essentially jumped the line and
received the covid vaccine before adults
who are vulnerable and essential workers
it's something we hear from viewers
almost every day
allegations of a person in power getting
vaccines for themselves their family
their friends here's what the governor's
chief of staff told our i-team
i think it is something that we continue
to explore to see
what that would look like as far as
taking a closer look at those and
and or ultimately having consequences
associated with those
we've also learned the state will start
tracking how much vaccine is going to
waste or be thrown out
health leaders could not provide an
estimate for those numbers today when we
asked
denise all right brian so let's get our
viewers up to date now on the
coronavirus numbers uh some improvement
tonight nevada's test positivity rate
sitting at 16.9 percent continues to
tick down just a little bit every day
statewide 750 new cases however
49 more people died overnight here in
clark county 652
of those new cases diagnosed and 38 of
those deaths
our recovery rate sitting at 93.4
percent
and if you need to get a covered test
there are appointments available that
are coming up this friday we can tell
you it's going to happen at the heritage
park senior facility
that's in henderson all you have to do
is go to the health district website to
schedule an appointment it's pretty busy
though as we know people trying to get
their vaccines
but they do have their website available
to make appointments for tests
we have the link on our website for you
at 8newsnow.com
a windy and warm day today with gusts up
in mount charleston up to 54 miles per
hour
live look outside right now another
gorgeous sunset now at 5
10 in the afternoon that's from our
camera looking towards the west
no showers here but take a look at the
high for the day today this is the other
big story 72 degrees
are high but we did not reach the record
on this date that was 77 degrees
back in 2018. wind alerts still remain
in effect with exception to the
mountains
this is for the las vegas valley in
effect until seven o'clock tonight that
includes the lake all the way down river
to laughlin
over to mojave county too where we still
anticipate some pretty big gusts at
least
we think the peak of it has already
passed and now we'll see those winds
start to subside a little mccarron
picking up gusts near 40 miles per hour
along with southern highlands
north las vegas at 36 henderson at 35
miles per hour here are your weather
headlines
staying breezy tomorrow but we have a
big cool down tomorrow
milder and nice for the big game this
weekend
i'll have all this and more and break
down your forecast for you
all straight ahead in your most accurate
forecast just minutes away
brian ted thank you as we get closer to
returning students to the classroom
dealing with physical and mental health
is on the top of lawmakers minds
ccsd has had more than 20 suicides since
students started learning from home that
was the subject of the first bill taken
up by the senate education committee
today
that is senate bill 36 it requires
schools to form a committee that creates
a plan
for dealing with epidemics emergency
situations
and the issue of suicide the teachers
union the clark county education
association
all supported the bill
the clark county school district has
experienced a mental health crisis since
the beginning of the school closures
that have resulted in a high number of
student suicides
educators administrators and students
need a plan to help prepare
and risk manage all future crises
emergencies and epidemics as we return
to
in person in high revised hybridized
excuse me learning
now no vote was taken today but both
health health districts around the state
did support the bill
as well well brian the biden
administration wants students to go back
to school
full time and says vaccinating teachers
does not have to be part of the equation
white house officials say they aren't
willing to push educators to the front
of the line
the cdc director says vaccination of
teachers is not a prerequisite
for the safe reopening of schools all
right so we asked you on twitter this
afternoon do you agree with the biden
administration that teachers don't need
the vaccine to return to the classroom
well here's a look at the numbers 33
percent say yep we're comfortable with
that
however the majority 66 percent disagree
[Music]
it is all systems go for the super bowl
on sunday can't wait super bowl 55
ron futrell live in studio joining us
now to talk about the chiefs and the
bucks in the big game
here we go brian yeah we're now only
let's see i have an app for this
three days 22 hours 21 minutes 47 46
45 seconds i do for the super bowl okay
the teams have already met once this
year in fact they met in tampa bay it
was an interesting game
chiefs jumped out to a big lead early it
was patrick mahomes and tyreek hill over
and over again
there was nothing tampa bay could do to
stop this combo the bucks came back
late in the game to make it close but
it's interesting the chiefs won that
game by three
and what's the spread for sunday's game
i think it's chief's favorite by three
and the old man tom brady 143 years old
he's ready to roll
give or take not many people have played
at my age and um i'm
i'm hoping that you know i can
uh give some of that wisdom to some of
the younger younger players who
want to do the same types of things the
biggest thing is going to be me just
getting the ball out of my hands uh
getting it to the play makers
that i have around me they have a really
good defense really good defensive line
uh linebackers bb's kind of the whole
the whole deal and so for me just trying
to make positive plays
and this is an interesting site in tampa
they're already putting the fake fans in
those seats cardboard cutouts there will
be real fans of the game around 22
000 so they're gonna have to mingle with
the cardboard cutouts
it should keep fights to a minimum i
hope also ted tells me it's looking more
and
more
like it's gonna rain on sunday so i'm
guessing the cardboard pads
are gonna look more lifeless that'll be
fun to see they'll look lifeless as the
game goes on to be slumped over
um also the bucks will be the home team
on sunday not just playing at home they
will be the home team the nfl alternates
every other year
which home team is there it's the afc
here's an easy way to remember
afc and even numbered years nfc in odd
number years that started in 1967 an odd
year
when the packers from the nfc being the
home team
in that game when they beat the chiefs
by the way in super bowl
uno brian ron it's going to be really
hard to get
the cardboard cutouts to pass the hot
dog down the aisle
what better way to watch the super bowl
than with your own mvp most valuable pet
from the animal foundation this weekend
the shelter has a big game tailgate
party
tomorrow through sunday adoption fees
wave for adult dogs
30 pounds or more and all adult cats it
includes spay or neutering
microchip and vaccines find your furry
friend on the animal foundation's
website then call the number there it is
955-5901 to set up
an adoption appointment well coming up
on channel 8
analysts have their eyes on lake mead's
water levels what the new data says
and why it is cause for concern
many are looking to support black owned
businesses in the las vegas community
i'll show you how a new food truck is
putting a fun twist
on classic barbecue
this portion
centennial hyundai
you're watching the valley's news leader
with brian loftus
denise valdez and ted florendo
live at five on eight news now
well february is black history month and
many in our community are looking to
support black owned businesses
here in las vegas new businesses are
popping up despite the challenges of the
pandemic
kate houston is live from charleston and
casino center where munchie's smokehouse
barbecue
is serving up some unique dishes in a
pretty unusual time
kate
yes that's right we're here at munchie's
smokehouse where they're taking classic
barbecue
and they're really just adding a fun
twist to it with dishes like tri-tip mac
and cheese
barbecue ramen and their fan favorite
rib tips
as a recently opened black-owned
business they're hoping to cultivate a
community here of all different styles
of food
i think our concepts are really fun and
they're new this is a tri-tip
for the past four months chaute du charm
and brandon jackson have been selling a
wide variety of barbecue dishes from
their new
food truck munchies smokehouse barbecue
we
just wanted to do a very different
fusion style barbecue we
make nachos out of 20 different chips
it's all a munchie style
what started as a dream soon became a
necessity when chaute lost her job right
before the pandemic
it was just scared for my family really
honestly
scared of like where we were going to be
if we were going to be homeless
so i had to start thinking about what we
were going to do
to make some money after a few setbacks
the food truck made its debut this past
october since then the lines haven't
stopped it's a great feeling it went
from
not knowing if it was going to be a good
decision to
with super bowl coming up just turning
away too many people
as a black-owned business jackson says
many customers have stopped by to try
their food for that very reason
and congratulate them on their success
and our smoker can hold 600 pounds of
meat at one time
now the duo is looking to support other
black owned businesses through a
pan-african food truck night
really just try to create something here
in las vegas i think that
there definitely needs to be something
that incorporates everybody not just
black but we're talking about like the
afro
latinos and our caribbean folks and all
of that
although the food truck has only been
open for a short time they're looking at
the possibility
of a brick and mortar location and
potentially franchising
to other parts of the united states
reporting from charleston and south
casino boulevard tonight kate houston
8 news now ted can we take a break right
now and go to charleston and south
casino boulevard and go ahead and get
some munchies because that looked
incredible you get you read my mind
because i was actually going to put in
an order to kate
to bring stuff back for us so we'll get
denise's order in just a bit so kate can
have
a big stuff uh stuff for us to bring
back
yeah everything all right it's that time
of the evening right dinner time
looking outside right now live look
shows skies clearing up just a little
bit we do have clouds off in the
distance there
they'll clear out even more overnight
with the passage of that cold front
that's going to bring some strong north
winds though overnight and also for
tomorrow not as strong as today though
currently outside 60 in centennial 63
summerlin and same goes for aliante
double six is for you downtown and north
las vegas
the east side you're still in the 70s at
this hour 71 for nellis
72 in sunrise mountain i just posted out
on social media that hey
somebody go out there and play out in it
because it's still comfortable rhodes
ranch
at 67 along with mountains edge seven
hills you're currently
at 67 degrees 65 for prompt double sixes
for those of you joining us up there
northeast clark in mesquite
and double sevens in lofland nice and
mild for you
there's our southwest radar the only
thing we can find as far as precip or
showers go is the form of snow showers
up near panguitch
and up there also into zion otherwise
we're remaining dry here throughout the
state southern tip of nevada getting
those clouds
and most of the thicker clouds of course
in southeast california and arizona but
they are staying dry
our wind does pick up again for tomorrow
this time they will be coming from the
north as you can see from those arrows
breezy tomorrow not the big winds like
we had today
decreasing a little more in the
afternoon and certainly tomorrow evening
so the winds really will be
more of a morning thing your weekend
looking good saturday 64
for the big game on sunday 65 partly
sunny
but we're looking at those winds also
staying light for tomorrow so
here's your forecast 44 degrees by
morning breezy
and mostly clear now you saw the skies
clear now
it will be chilly and then 58 for
tomorrow
breezy and cooler those gusts this time
up to 25
possibly up to 35 for the lake we'll
keep those winds like we said
elevated for at least the first half of
the day for tomorrow your highs
neighborhood by neighborhood let's start
it off in centennial hills 56 for you up
there in sky canyon
and providence 57 for mountains edge
summerlin at 55
north las vegas at 57 will be at 56 for
henderson green valley at 60 even
we'll be at 55 for boulder city 56 in
loughlin
you'll have a high tomorrow at 65
degrees so 70s today
cooler tomorrow only in the high 50s we
told you we'd have a cooldown and look
at those mid 60s that we're going to see
not only later on the week and the
weekend
but in the next week too along with
breezy winds we think on
monday and tuesday that of course is
your most
accurate